if insomniac song of the deep was a
children's book or a graphic novel I
would have no problem singing its
praises to anyone of any age it's
captivating portrayal of a young girl's
undersea adventure not only looks and
sounds beautiful it also tells a story
that sparkles with all the wonder danger
and timelessness of a classic fable
glowing cuddle pups swam through the
dark caverns heedless of their deadly
surroundings maybe they were tougher
than they looked even the stinging in
enemies seemed to avoid them but song
the deep is not a book rather it's a
relatively uninventive Metroidvania
style action-adventure title whose
gameplay turns tedious and frustrating a
little too often to forgive if you're
willing to weather the storm however
sawing the deep still delivers moments
of fun and more importantly an
entrancing well crafted story
the setup is simple and sweet when her
father fails to return from his latest
fishing expedition
the young resourceful Marin cobbles
together a ramshackle submarine and goes
looking for him beneath the waves she
finds a spellbinding world full of
sunken ships hidden treasure hideous
monsters and mysterious cities to reach
the lost graveyard of ships Marin would
have to cross the foul and treacherous
region known as Watchers Hollow the
colorful imaginative backdrops play
perfectly on the pirate tales we loved
as kids
evoking a sense of wonder that anyone
can connect with the music too is subtle
but evocative shifting from ahh and
tranquility to danger and dread as the
tension starts to mount the story itself
is well written like a Pixar film it
never condescends to its audience with
watered-down exposition or moronic humor
instead it carefully and clearly builds
a world expertly introducing important
elements early but we're bringing them
back just in time to save the day later
on as you play you'll receive little
bursts of narration that feel like you
flipped the page of a storybook Marin
held her breath and douve out through
the submarines hatch these moments are
not only smartly paced they offer
context and insight without simply
explaining what's happening like some
distant radio partner dumping exposition
in your ear ultimately song the deep
provides a rare and welcome example of
exceptional storytelling in games
unfortunately the games mechanics don't
deserve quite that much praise you'll
spend most of your time freely exploring
the 2d world in Marin sub carefully
maneuvering through treacherous areas
while gradually gathering upgrades once
bolted on these upgrades allow her to
smash different types of barriers and
enter previously inaccessible areas you
know classic Metroidvania stuff
for the most part exploration proves
enjoyable but the puzzles you encounter
along the way especially those that
reward you with optional upgrades and
currency tend to sink the experience you
might need to say grab a see mine with
meirin's finicky tethered claw and use
it to explode a reinforced door one
glance of the scenario and you know okay
mind orb got it but dragging the
uncooperative mind to the door without
bumping something and prematurely
detonating the device might make you
pull your hair out and that's just one
example
several repeated puzzle types are
frustratingly time-consuming or worse
boring you'll inevitably spend tons of
time waiting waiting for the search
light to pass waiting for the mine to
respawn waiting for your boost to
recharge waiting for an ocean current to
stop later puzzles involving reflected
beams of light can be even more
infuriating simply because they're so
damn protracted in fairness the puzzles
do grow more inventive once you acquire
later upgrades being able to float a
bomb by blasting it with ice or flip a
switch through a wall using a sonar
poles for example opens up some creative
possibilities I even uncovered a couple
delightful aha moments like tricking a
school of fish into eating the kelp
encasing a chest in-between puzzles
there's always a chance you'll be
attacked by some especially nefarious
sea life thankfully song the deep comes
prepared with simplistic but generally
enjoyable combat mechanics then you can
defeat enemies by smashing them with a
claw or shooting them with various types
of missiles the controls utilize only
one stick meaning you must always move
and aim in the same direction that isn't
necessarily a problem but it does
underscore the simplistic nature of the
mechanics you can dodge attacks and
repel enemies with your sonar once you
find the requisite upgrades and darting
around blasting loads of deadly
jellyfish does feel empowering but the
generous health and energy levels
usually allow you to just pummel your
attackers without much need for deeper
strategy even boss battles mainly
recycle the same basic repetitive
enemies
the only real challenge comes from
eluding the invincible death squids that
populate a specific part of the world
being repeatedly one hit killed and
forced to restart from a distance bond
is the scientific opposite of fun still
song the deeps mix of combat puzzle
solving and exploration generally land
somewhere around fine even if it wavers
between aggravating and enjoyable in the
process and although the game tests your
patience more often than it tests your
skill it's thrilling world an excellent
story keep the experience of float
through it all